it's Wednesday the 22nd of February
shamama begum expected to find out later
whether she's won an appeal against the
decision to strip her British
citizenship for joining the so-called
Islamic State in Syria
signs of a breakthrough nurses begin new
intensive talks with the health
secretary this morning
that you have nursing pauses its plan
strikes as the head of the union says
she's confident of negotiating a fair
deal on pay
President Biden promises support for
Ukraine will not waver as Vladimir Putin
prepares for a major rally in Moscow
after Russia's latest nuclear warning
the U.S President Joe Biden is due to
meet with NATO allies from the East
later today
the dup says there are still issues to
be resolved as the Prime Minister tries
to get a new deal on post-brexit trading
Arrangements in Northern Ireland Over
The Line
Morrison's joins Asda in limiting the
sale of some fruit and veg from today
with a warning the shortages could last
for weeks
come fly with me let's fly let's fly
away
a new customer survey reveals the worst
short haul Airlines for British
passengers
[Music]
morning everybody Shema begum is due to
find out later on today if she's won an
appeal against the government's decision
to strip her of her British citizenship
Miss began was 15 years old when she and
two other schoolgirls from East London
traveled to Syria to join the so-called
Islamic State she had her British
citizenship revoked on National Security
grounds by the then-home secretary Sajid
Javid shortly after she was found in a
refugee camp in 2019 the home office has
argued that she remains a threat to
National Security while her lawyers have
argued she was a victim of child
trafficking and is now de facto
stateless let's take you through what
happened February 2015. shamima begum
and two other girls left their homes in
East London and flew to Turkey from
where they traveled on to Syria four
years later after the fall of ish she
was fired by a times journalist nine
months pregnant in a refugee camp in
Northeast Syria she told Sky News at the
time that she wanted to come home but
didn't regret her decision to join the
terrorist group
later that month in February 2019 the UK
government served noticed that it
intended to strip Ms begum of her
citizenship on National Security grounds
they said that because of her parents
being a Bangladeshi she could apply to
go there instead in 2020 the court of
appeal ruled that the only way she could
have have her case heard fairly was if
she was permitted to come to the UK but
that was immediately challenged by the
government her return was blocked by the
Supreme Court with the home office
continuing to argue that she posed
significant National Security risks Ms
began tolsgan used that she had never
been involved in any atrocities and then
last November her latest attempt to win
the right to travel back to the UK began
in London that's expected to conclude
later this morning
the consequence of today will not mean
that shamima begum would be brought back
because the British government is
refusing to bring back the large
majority of the adults who are detained
in Northeast Syria what it will mean is
that for the first time uh a court will
be saying
that the Home Secretary urge when they
made their decision to strip her for
citizenship
Tamara's here um
so what happens today so today we learn
whether she's won her appeal against the
decision that she's not allowed to
return to the UK that latest decision in
November this is the latest twist as you
were hearing of this long-running legal
battle that's been raging since the
former Home Secretary Sajid Javid
revoked shamima begum's citizenship back
in 2019 she initially appealed on the
grounds that she was made stateless but
a tribunal found in the government's
favor on that saying that she could have
access to Bangladeshi citizenship she
then appealed back in November on the
grounds that she had been trafficked to
Syria and her lawyers said she was
recruited transported transferred and
harbored in Syria for the purposes of
sexual exploitation and marriage to an
adult male now the government's position
is that the fact that she was 15 and the
fact that she may have been radicalized
online was all considered in the
decision to revoke her citizenship and
that people traffic to Syria can still
be a national or security risk and they
still believe she is a national security
risk so we'll hear about the results of
that this is all being heard by a
special immigration appeals commission
that's a tribunal where basically the
secret Services can give evidence
covertly and Mr Justice J is due to rule
on that appeal this morning but she has
not been very successful in her legal
actions so far and it was seen that she
may be running out of road yeah what
happens if she loses this one do we know
you if she loses this one on the latest
grounds it's not clear that she has many
other options and that even if a court
did find in her favor how would she end
up coming back to the UK because the
British government is not going to
facilitate that happening and just a
thought about Sajid Javid he was the one
that decided when he was home secretary
that she couldn't be a British citizen
anymore he said if you subsequently he
said if you knew what I knew you
wouldn't want to in this country will we
ever know what he knew well it doesn't
look like it at the moment the
government's position is that although
many other countries have taken back a
lot of the people who joined Islamic
State and the British government has
been criticized for not doing so for not
bringing them back putting them on trial
the government's position is that a lot
of this evidence could not be heard in
an open court and a lot of the evidence
couldn't be gathered because it comes
from Syria so the government have been
criticized for letting people
essentially rot in refugee camps in
Syria former Islamic State Fighters and
the decision to strip her of her
citizenship on the grounds that she
could have the citizenship of another
country although she doesn't actually
have Bangladeshi citizenship does have
implications for other people in a
similar situation okay fine thank you
thanks a lot
the head of the nurses union says she's
confident about negotiating a fair pay
deal as they enter what being described
as intensive talks with the government
this morning the Royal College of
Nursing has agreed to pause their next
major strike while talks are ongoing
which had been planned to run 48 hours
from the 1st of March
we certainly will
um as we've always said we will put our
plans on the table they can put their
plans on the table but I'm confident
that we will come out with a therapist
settlement for our nursing staff you've
Becky's standing by for us this morning
at the Department of Health so nurses
are a special case are they
sorry Kate just repeat that again I
didn't catch that no problem at all
Becky I was just saying does it seems
like nurses are going to be considered
as a special case
well perhaps Kay and certainly other
unions uh will be looking on and
watching closely what happens here some
might be unhappy that nurses perhaps
have been treated as a special case but
also it could be the Breakthrough that
we need here in these talk to communions
and the government in terms of nurses
the big sticking point so far has been
that the government has not been willing
to talk about a further pay rise for
this pay year which actually ends in
March the fact that these talks are
happening at all would suggest they have
some flexibility on that they also of
course need to talk about next year's
pay rise the government has said that
3.5 would be an affordable amount to
raise NHS payback perhaps they are
flexible on that too especially after
the news yesterday that public borrowing
is way down could that mean more money
for public sector workers we shall have
to wait and see but certainly a step in
the right direction these talks between
nurses and the government as you
mentioned nurses have called off that
48-hour strike that would have included
emergency workers good news for patients
and NHS leaders but the big question
here is Will this these talks today set
the bar for other talks between unions
and the government the government needs
to end this wave of industrial action
all their talks in the good nurses be a
step towards that okay for now thank you
under 72 hour strike by ambulance
workers enters its final day today
ambulance staff belonging to the unite
Union in Wales and the north west region
of England are taking industrial action
overpay unite has also announced two
further strikes in Wales in March it's
calling on the Welsh government to do
the right thing and get around the table
meanwhile the head of a teacher's Union
has said they won't call off their
strikes after the education secretary
invited unions to engage in formal talks
on pay conditions and reform
in response to Jillian Keegan's request
joined to General Secretary of the
National Education Union Kevin Courtney
said the Neu is pleased that the
secretary of state has agreed with the
Prime Minister and Chancellor to move
into substantive formal talks with the
Neu to end the dispute between us our
disputes is about seeking pay increases
for teachers which at least match
increases and for any pay Rises to be
fully funded in school budgets we are
willing to talk at any time but there is
nothing substantial in the Secretary of
State's letter that suggests to us we
should call off strikes for next week
uh Joe Biden will meet Eastern NATO
leaders today in a show of support after
the Russian president suspended a
nuclear arms control treaty Vladimir
Putin also accused the U.S of turning
Ukraine's war into a global conflict in
his own major address yesterday the U.S
president declared that Ukraine will
never be a victory for Russia while our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes is in key for us this morning
um just a day or so away now from the
anniversary of the start of the war as
the snow begins to fall again where you
are what is the view of what these two
big hitters are saying in the middle
there in Ukraine
foreign
just had some more air raid sirens here
it's quite
um it's quite haunting really because I
remember being here on the 24th of
February when the full scale Invasion
started and hearing that sound for the
first time almost exactly a year later
it's it's become part unfortunately of
of normal life obviously people here
keep carrying on really when you hear
the sirens
um but over the last few months there
have been significant missile strikes
including in the capital city which
really underlines that when you hear
those signs those Sirens Russia's war
effort is continuing it's raging in the
East still where the front line is being
fiercely contested especially around
that city of bakmut there's expectations
that both sides will be seeking to
launch some kind of new offensives the
Russians have seemingly been trying to
ramp up the amount of artillery fire
that they're launching against these
Ukrainian positions to try to push
forward throwing waves as well of Wagner
mercenaries against the Ukrainian lines
but the ukrainians have been managing to
hold firm but both sides incurring
horrendous losses so yes while you have
these two leaders Joe Biden who came
here for the first time since the full
scale Invasion a couple of days ago on a
hugely significant moment and him
speaking and then also the Russian
president speaking caught in the middle
here and the country that really is at
the heart of all this Ukraine the war
shows no end in sight okay for no thank
you
um at 9 30 the Lithuanian foreign
minister Gabriella slansbergis will be
here to talk about what he thinks lays
ahead for the war in Ukraine
now despite ongoing discussions there's
still no deal for the Northern Ireland
protocol where she soon act has said
that Britain and the EU have an
understanding on what needs to be done
around the Northern Ireland protocol but
that work still needs to be done okay uh
I don't know do you understand the
Northern Ireland protocol do you
understand what's happening in Northern
Ireland how can they resolve it the man
who does know of course our Island
correspondent uh David Blevins Chief
correspondent forgive me um how do they
fix it
well squaring that Circle won't be easy
because there has to be a border
somewhere as a result of brexit either
on the island of Ireland and many people
feel that contravenes the Good Friday
agreement making it uh very clear that
there's a division again between the
North and the republic or it has to be
in the Irish sea which clearly in the
view of unionists draws a line down the
middle of the UK and so the prime
minister is struggling it seems now to
get this deal over the line because he's
under pressure both from the e or G the
hard line breaks it to your wing of the
Tory party and from the Democratic
unionists but what they often forget of
course is that it was Boris Johnson who
signed up to this deal with the EU in
order to in his own words get brexit
done despite having repeatedly promised
the dup that there would be no border in
the RSC that's what he had to say when
he attended the party's conference back
in 2018.
we will under no circumstances have a
hard border there will be no physical
checks or infrastructure at the Border
in Northern Ireland no British
conservative government could or should
sign up to any such Arrangement we're a
UK government why would we put checks on
Goods going from Ni to GB or GB to ni it
doesn't make sense
so he was the man who did the deal with
the EU but of course immediately deal
yes oh and ready deal but the dup
immediately felt they'd been thrown onto
the bus so to speak and they regard this
deal as a as a problem because it raises
the question of where Northern Ireland's
future lies they believe it creates a
compromise in Northern Ireland's place
in the United Kingdom even though it's
just a trade deal it creates an economic
United Ireland which of course in their
view paves the way to a political United
Ireland and that's why they want this
deal scrapped and although Sir Jeffrey
Donaldson leader of the dup says Richie
sunac has made some progress the dup and
the ERG met last night and the dup said
there were still elements of the the
reported de la they haven't seen the
detail yet that they're not happy with
particularly the role of the European
court of justice because it would
continue to have jurisdiction over trade
disputes in Northern Ireland but of
course because of brexit it no longer
has jurisdiction over any other part of
the United Kingdom will a deal ever be
done
but that is a good question but Northern
Ireland desperately needs a deal to be
done because the dup are currently
boycotting power sharing the
administration at the heart of the Good
Friday agreement so Northern Ireland
like everywhere else in the United
Kingdom is dealing with a cost of living
crisis a health care crisis an energy
crisis but there's no one in office to
address these things they're being sort
of handled at arm's length by the
Northern Ireland secretary and his team
in London but if there is no deal
effectively power sharing is over the
Good Friday agreement is dead in the
25th anniversary year of the Good Friday
agreement that would be extraordinary
and what happens next things have
changed a lot in the last 25 years
unionists are not the dominant Force
there's a nationalist Shin Fein first
Minister designate standing by ready to
take office if she's ever given the
opportunity to do that so the suggestion
that we would simply revert back to
direct rule from Westminster I don't
think is feasible there's no legislative
provision for it any longer and
potentially Shin Fein could also be in
charge in Ireland that is that is right
there they're doing very well in the
polls Mary Lou McDonald who I know was
on the program talking to you recently
uh is um in the view of many people
poised to become the first uh Shin Fein
t-shirt in the next general election
whether or not that happens well there's
still a possibility you could have Shin
Fein in office as a as prime minister in
the Republic of Ireland as first
minister in Northern Ireland if that's
not an indication that things have
dramatically changed in the last 25
years okay I don't know what it is okay
and you've got a surprise interview that
you can't tell us about but it's um
tomorrow and everybody's going to want
to hear what your guest has to say but
I'm not going to say anymore thanks very
much indeed David thank you and reminded
that prime minister's questions is on
today at 12 noon we'll be bringing that
to you live here on Sky News
looking at some of the day's other news
for you now and Morrisons is joining
Asda today to introduce limits on
purchases of some fruits and vegetables
there's a warning that the shortage of
tomatoes peppers and other produce is
likely to last for several weeks a
combination of bad weather and transport
problems in southern Europe and North
Africa is blamed for Bare shells with
some supermarkets rationing produce
sales the environment secretary to raise
coffee plans to address food security
when she gives a speech to Farmers later
on today
unions believe an announcement could be
made as soon as today about potential
job losses that British steel site and
scum thought they say they were told
earlier this month that the
chinese-owned company was considering
closing Coke Ovens Sky News understands
that the UK government officials will
fly to China this week hoping to secure
a state funding package worth as much as
300 million pounds
a report out of the Lords predicts the
government will miss its targets to
switch people from gas boilers to heat
pumps ministers want the green a cheaper
heating technology put into 600 000
homes every year by 2028 the environment
and climate change committee said
despite household grants the take-up
rate is still too low
joining us now Minister Veterans Affairs
Johnny Mercer High okay how are you I'm
very well thanks for joining us I don't
think you've been on the sofa when I've
been in previously so it's nice to see
you thanks for coming in what are we
going to do about the Northern Ireland
protocol and the on-pass that has been
created look I think uh it's clear that
all nine protocol doesn't work for any
size in Northern Ireland the prime
minister's doing everything he can to
resolve that and get to a solution that
preserves The Good Friday agreement and
uh make sure that there's the free flow
of trade in Northern Ireland I you know
that's been going on for some time I
think and uh you know we're looking
forward to resolving that and getting on
and realizing all the benefits of brexit
are you going to resolve it well look
the premises in negotiations at the
moment isn't it and uh you know he had
good discussions last week with the
European Union uh he's got good
engagement going on at the moment with
with other MPS and uh you know we'll see
what comes out of this yeah but because
of brexit it has to be a border
somewhere Boris Johnson's said time and
time again ERG saying the same thing
that there cannot be a border in the
Irish sea so that would mean there'd
have to be a border between Ireland and
Northern Ireland and that would be
against the Good Friday agreement so
where does that leave you it's okay
obviously I mean it feels like we're
we're stuck in a Time Warner doesn't it
because we're talking about same things
that we've been talking about four or
five years let's let's give the Prime
Minister a chance to come out with
something right he's attacking this uh
he is throwing everything he can and so
he voted for and campaigned hard for
brexit right so he's not going to sell
anyone out or come up with a solution
that's unfair or doesn't deliver on what
he thinks is brexit I think let's give
him a chance give him the opportunity to
uh to bring some sort of resolution to
the protocol and then let's get behind
him and get on with all the other
challenges that we Face across this
country at the moment a deal this week
I don't know I hope so uh but let's see
what happens you know he's working hard
and let's see what happens talk to me
back uh you're brief you're not seeing
your money for projects helping yeah
veterans tell me more yeah so look uh
the health Innovation fund we're
launching today we um you know clearly
we're on a drive to make this the best
country in the world to be a veteran
there are some veterans who will wake up
this morning with really difficult
wounds that still don't heal and really
you know bed sores and pressure sores
and things like that and uh we're
investing at five million pounds in
technology companies and other companies
across the UK 22 different companies uh
looking at really Innovative and you
know exciting technologies that will
help people improve and heal their
wounds you know I was at a company
yesterday that looked at electronic
classes right where you can you know put
these pluses on people who've had
amputations and so on and pass a current
through them and actually start to heal
some of these wounds that haven't healed
for such a long time so
um look it's really exciting I accept it
it's niche right but I think the way the
country looks after veterans is a big
marker by which we should be judged I
think that's fundamentally changed under
this government and um you know it's
another it's another Waypoint on on the
way to making this the best country in
the world
you have championed the troubles Legacy
bill you seem to be the only person that
does why are you continuing to plow on
with it well I don't think I am the only
person who does I think obviously the
Airways will be dominated by people who
don't like it which is supposed by all
parties in Northern Ireland the Irish
government and yeah yeah of course and
it's going to be right and if uh and if
it
um if if they they were happy with it I
didn't I don't think we'd hear anything
about it the troubles the trolls Legacy
building online is incredibly difficult
right it's incredibly sensitive you're
dealing with really really difficult
issues that have
um reared their heads over the last 25
years since the Good Friday agreement I
think it's pretty clear that the war has
happened and you've seen this over the
course of the last year
um is is not fair it's not fair on
anyone it's not delivering outcomes for
victims it's not delivering uh fairness
for veterans and uh um you know the
government was elected on Manifesto
promised to to bring that to a closer
and bring you know bring some sort of uh
reconciliation and and resolution for
for victims in this space and you know
the government should be commended for
that it's not easy right solving what
has happened in Northern Ireland and
dealing with Legacy is not easy you
can't just throw slogans at it and say
you know we're going to open up the
books or protect it it doesn't work like
that Legacy is really really difficult
um and if you're if you're really
committed to helping the victims uh
understand what has happened then you
would support this bill
and sort of encourage the transparency
that it presents and the northern
secretary has done a great job in
bringing communities with him and all
that obviously I totally accept that
everyone is against this and I unders in
Northern Ireland and I respect that you
know that that is their job and they
represent particular parts of the
population
that's because it offers an amnesty yeah
but there is no way it doesn't offer an
amnesty right first up it's not an
amnesty if people who thinks it's an
ambulously you don't know what an
amnesty is secondarily you know that you
cannot have laws that disaggregate
between claimants between those who
serve in the military and those
um who didn't so look we have to operate
in the real world we have to operate
with the world as we see it is it is it
where we you know a solution that uh you
know we can all we all want to see well
look I don't think you're going to get
that in in Legacy I think some of these
crimes the evidence just doesn't exist
anymore we have a duty to make sure that
uh existing structures are not abused
and um
um you know by one side or the other and
that we try and deliver uh fairness for
uh victims in this space at the same
time not allowed the abuse of our
veterans talk to me about shamima begum
should she be allowed to return to the
UK look I think there's a lot of
information in the space with with her
that has not been made public
um you know the uh Jared when he was
home secretary he made he made his
decision around that and uh I support
him in that I think that case is going
uh through the courts today let's see
what they say but look it's in in spaces
like this with National Security there's
so much information that is not in the
public domain and you have to trust the
processes and Trust the uh the Secretary
of State like Sajid when he made that
decision and the courts to make sure
that we come to the right conclusion I'm
sure she'll be treated fairly 2015 when
all this happened she was a kid she was
groomed
you know that's something the court will
take into consideration that's you know
it's not for me now can we not um put
her on trial I mean is it not a place
where we can put again but they are they
are working through all these all these
questions in the court and um
look I don't have a view because I'm not
I'm not uh I'm not um I'm sure you
decided on all the uh high side
intelligence around her
um you know clearly if she's a threat to
this country then um you know we have a
job to keep people safe and uh that's
what the government's determined to do
and we'll do what's your view on uh
nurses being a special case when it
comes to pay uh rewards look I think uh
I think the strikes are really
unfortunate there's a lot of people in
Plymouth who who work in the public
sector I will always argue for them to
get paid more but you know you're
chasing a really difficult problem here
the biggest challenge is inflation and
that's driving up prices across uh
Plymouth and across the country and you
know people like the governor of the
bank of England himself have said that
you know if you continue to chase that
with pay Rises you're never going to end
it so I don't think this is a binary
issue that that you can you know say
well the right to do is I think these
negotiations need to continue people
aren't negotiating good faith we'll get
to the end of it look I I think uh you
could you can argue as a special case
for for lots of different professions
like that Junior doctors and so on I
think uh you know I think these
negotiations need to be conducted in
good faith and I think we need to bring
these strikes to an end because there's
enormous pressure on Health Services
people in my constituency want to see
their health services working properly
and these strikes and withdrawing of
Labor only makes that more difficult
okay just before I let you go we both
know that you're the king of reality TV
um do you fancy following in Matt
Hancock's footsteps no
thanks for joining us cheers
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
overnight cloud and rain will be slow to
clear Southern Parts but for much of the
country there'll be a much cooler field
to the day
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
look at the impact of climate change on
the planet the right half of the screen
shows how the UK's power is currently
being produced always watch out for the
cold don't we and it's down below a half
of one percent at the moment on the top
left you can see how much warmer the
Earth is now than it was in 1880 it's
gone up to
1.26 degrees warmer you need to keep an
eye on that it goes to two we're in a
lot of trouble
um total CO2 emissions in millions of
tons in real time is to the bottom left
still to come on the program we'll tell
you the short haul airline that has been
given the lowest consumer satisfaction
rating by consumer Group which that to
come
[Music]
the consumer Group which has put out its
rankings of short haul Airlines based on
consumer and customer satisfaction
thousands of passengers were surveyed
about things like boarding experience
cabin environment and how comfy the
seats are
well uh we'll start with the third from
bottom that is Euro Wings overall which
gave it a score of 53 percent
it was just ahead of Ryanair the biggest
name in short haul flights they managed
52 percent
and at the bottom of the pack is
hungary's wiz air
48 it scored just one or two stars in
all key categories including value for
money and cleanliness and his defense
was their spokesman said they do
everything possible to get passengers to
where they're going without delay and I
did fly with them to Moldova a couple of
weeks ago and they certainly got us
there on time so I can agree certainly
on that a bit lots of speculation about
how close the government is to securing
a new deal to fix post-brexit trading
Arrangements in Northern Ireland joined
now about a conservative MP for Harwich
and North Essex and the liaison
committee chair saburra Jenkins hello to
you sir Bernard thanks for joining us on
the program this morning
thank you sorry I can't be in your
studio today yeah me too hopefully
you'll come again uh very soon always
welcome how close are we do you think to
a deal
well I fear not very close because
what's been happening is the government
has been strenuously trying to reach an
agreement but within very narrow
confines that the EU has set they
weren't uh consider reopening their
mandate to look at new ways of
approaching the whole question of
Northern Ireland in the in post-brexit
and there are consequences that the
negotiations have been on a very narrow
mandate set by the EU and it doesn't
look as though the government can
resolve the power sharing crisis with
any deal that will emerge from these
negotiations
okay so brexit means there has to be a
border somewhere where should that
border be
well the board is actually
um the border that people mind about
that uh the EU Minds most about is the
north south border all the discussions
in this negotiation have been about how
to stop non-compliant Goods getting into
the Republic of Ireland and and to that
extent the borders in the wrong place
um and the Border was put
in the North and the RSC to try and
avoid offending one community in
Northern Ireland and it finished up deep
defending another community in Northern
Ireland and you'll remember okay during
the negotiations there was lots of talk
about what they called alternative
Arrangements of having some kind of
invisible north-south border
um between Northern Ireland and the
Republic of Ireland but that was ditched
because there wasn't enough time well
the obvious answer is to go back to that
proposal now that we have unlimited time
and aim towards creating a customs
Frontier between Northern Ireland and
the Republic of Ireland but without
actual checks or infrastructure at the
border and the Border already has a vac
border and we don't have vat checks at
the border there's an excise duty border
there's different levels of excise duty
each side of the Border but we don't
have checks at the border to police that
there's a security border there's
actually a a people border and usually
you have checkpoints at a border to stop
the people that are going across that
shouldn't be going across but we don't
even have that that so it should not be
too difficult to have a customs Frontier
without infrastructure in a north-south
border so you think the Border should be
on the dividing the North and uh a
north-south divide as opposed to one in
the Irish sea what would that mean for
the Good Friday agreement
well that would restore the Good Friday
agreement because what so offends the
unionist community in Northern Ireland
and this is by far the most important
thing as you as one of your speakers
were saying earlier
um the collapse of the Good Friday
agreement is an absolute catastrophe
political tensions are rising
um there's no there's nobody objecting
in Northern Ireland to the board of
being in a different place or there
being different arrangements to deal
with this issue
um but it deeply deeply offends the
universe community that this was imposed
on them it is a cardinal principle of
the act of Union of 1800 which binds
Northern Ireland into the United Kingdom
is that there is one internal market for
the United Kingdom and now there is a
customs Frontier between the United
Kingdom between the Great Britain and
Northern Ireland and that separates
Northern Ireland from the rest of the
United Kingdom it also means that
because the protocol puts the Northern
Ireland into the EU single market and
out of the UK internal Market EU law
applies and
Northern Ireland like no other part of
the United Kingdom but the people in
Northern Ireland have no say over those
laws
so there's lots of Rumblings back bench
Rumblings and all sorts of threats of
people resigning and goodness knows uh
what else the Prime Minister really
could just turn to labor to get this
through couldn't he
well he could and it was odd that
kirstama said don't worry we'll support
you whatever you sign
um and not very States would like to
look at an agreement to think about
supporting something before you've even
seen the text of the agreement and also
it's very odd that the people who say oh
just sign just sign they never mentioned
the Good Friday agreement The Good
Friday agreement is by far the most
important factor here the protocol was
put in place to protect the good variety
agreement article one of the protocol is
about protecting the Good Friday
agreement but it's not protecting the
Good Friday agreement it's undermining
The Good Friday agreement so that surely
is an invitation to perhaps get the Good
Friday parties around the table again to
say look how shall we sort this out the
EU has a very legitimate concern they
don't want non-compliant goods Crossing
from Northern Ireland into the EU single
Market
but the protocol is not the only way of
addressing that we should be looking at
a different protocols
okay but
over the line for the Prime Minister
what would you do
I don't think the prime well I'm not a
minister but um the Prime Minister I
don't think will do that I think the
Prime Minister will want to talk to the
labor party and say look the reason why
I'm not signing this deal is because the
Good Friday agreement is by far the most
important factor here and then and it
would be unconscionable to sign an
agreement with the EU that cementing
plays the protocol which is destroying
the peace in Northern Ireland and that's
that's what it seems some people are
urging the prime minister to do I don't
think people do that
uh you're not a minister but you are a
member of the uh conservative party when
it comes to being an MP you would
continue to fight on would you
well I'm I have many responsibilities in
Parliament and um I take them very
seriously
um it gives a great deal of meaning to
my life I'm not about to pack it in if
that's what you're asking that's exactly
what I was asking you
well I'm carrying on thank you very much
okay
I am actually for now let's see got a
contracts renewal coming up shortly
let's see it's hard work getting up at
three o'clock in the morning believe me
um do you think we'll see a deal this
week
no no because the protocol itself is
fundamentally incompatible the protocol
applies law EU law in Northern Ireland
and there is no democracy I mean even
there was a House of Lords subcommittee
that is full of people who voted to the
invaded Lee voted in Maine and they all
unanimously said there is a democratic
deficit that has to be addressed about
the protocol and I the answer is to
include Northern Ireland back in the
internal markets of the United Kingdom
uh to make a new protocol attached to
the trading Corporation agreement which
is a permanent agreement the protocol
was only intended to be temporary uh it
it it's got its own flaws about
reviewing or superseding uh the protocol
it was meant to be a stop Gap until
there was a better solution well we need
a better solution now I always get
confused about Boris Johnson saying that
it was an oven ready deal and and now
he's saying he didn't really mean it and
it was only temporary etc etc and he's
up to all sorts of Mischief isn't he in
the in the background
well um Boris Johnson I think did the
best of a bad job on the basis that it's
a temporary agreement and it can be
superseded and improved but the EU is at
the moment refusing to contemplate that
uh I think if the EU reflects on the
deteriorating security situation or
Northern Ireland because of the collapse
of power sharing and the undermining of
the Good Friday agreement even they will
come to the table eventually and realize
uh that peace in Northern Ireland is the
primary concern and frankly this is a
storm and a teacup for the vast majority
of other member states they're not
interested in having a rare with the UK
over this this can be settled but I
don't think it'll be settled if the
existing protocol remains in place when
do you think it'll be subtle
well I hope by the 25th anniversary I
mean
um this is a very big moment Joe Biden
President Joe Biden is going to come
over and celebrate the 25th anniversary
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement
it'll be an odd celebration if there's
no power sharing because that's the
foundation and bear in mind that the
protocol itself was imposed on Northern
Ireland it didn't go through the Good
Friday processes for concerns from both
communities
um The Good Friday agreement says no key
decisions should be taken in Northern
Ireland without the consent of both
communities well that the protocol never
had the consent of both communities so
it's a violation of itself of the
principle of the Good Friday agreement
okay it's good to talk to you um so
Bernard again sorry you're not with us
um hopefully we'll see you in the studio
soon thanks a lot
thank you very much indeed bye-bye bye
bye
in other news um child abuse image
crimes have reached record levels
according to the nspcc and for the first
time virtual reality headsets are being
used to view such material Rachel
hasmore
Roxy was just 13 when a 17 year old boy
she'd never met coerced her into sending
sexual images on Snapchat
my whole life was about
doing what he told me to do and hiding
it from everybody
and then obviously the more photos he
had the more he had to Blackmail me with
until eventually he asked me to send a
video him and his friend they just
completely owned me at that point like I
had absolutely no control
she was just a child and the impact was
devastating
the kind of Shame really just buried me
and I I ended up becoming very ill like
self-harmed a lot I stopped sleeping and
eventually I was hospitalized because I
ended up having a psychotic episode but
Roxy is one of thousands
last year police recorded more than 30
000 offenses involving obscene images of
children in England and Wales the
highest number ever of the cases where a
social media or gaming site was used to
share the pictures Snapchat was the most
popular followed by meta's sites like
Facebook Instagram and WhatsApp and for
the first time ever virtual reality
headsets were also used to view child
abuse images
this is an emerging threat and that's
one of the reasons why we have been
pressing the government to commit to
having a child safety advocacy body
because we think it's crucial to have a
champion for children who can act as an
early warning system a Snapchat
spokesperson said any sexual abuse of
children is a borrent and illegal once
aware of any sexual content exploiting
miners we immediately remove it delete
the account and Report the offender a
meta spokesperson said this horrific
content is banned on our apps and we
report instances of child sexual
exploitation to authorities our work in
this area is never done and will
continue to do everything we can to keep
the content off our apps I mean I look
so young also why did anyone want a
photo of somebody okay Roxy can't get
her childhood back but she hopes
speaking out will protect other children
from going through the horror that she
did Rachel Venable's Sky News
and if you have been affected by
anything in that report please contact
the Samaritans on
116123 or email Joe samaritans.org
look at the front of some of the morning
papers for you the Chimes leaves with
Putin abandoning Russia's Arms Control
treaty with the U.S and a warning it
could lead to nuclear weapons chess the
guardian leads with the Royal College of
Nursing suspending its plan strike
action next week
Financial Times reports which you soon
may be offering a five percent pay rise
for people in the public sector to stop
the wave of strikes the telegraph
reports that next year's settlement
could be three and a half percent if the
government gets its way the eye says the
PM is ready to let MPS resign over
attempts to block his new brexit deal on
Northern Ireland marriage
and the Daily Express says some shops
are being forced to introduce rationing
of fruit and vegetables after shortages
and many people on benefits will be
worse off until 2025 according to the
institute for fiscal studies the
organization has won the annual
operating of benefits in April will
merely take them back to around the real
level they were at a year earlier due to
a failure in payments keeping up with
inflation
the Metropolitan Police have released
new CCTV footage of a missing couple
Constance Martin and Mark Gordon couple
have been missing with their baby for
more than six weeks police believe it's
likely that they're running out of cash
the family of the American Civil Rights
icon Malcolm X is planning to sue the
FBI the CIA and the nypd4 100 million
dollars accusing them of playing a role
in his death Alicia Shabazz says the
agencies conspired to and executed their
plan to assassinate her father in 1965.
shama begum who was just 15 when she
traveled to Syria to join the so-called
Islamic State in 2015 is due to find out
whether she's won an appeal against the
decision to remove her British
citizenship joined Now by Steve Valdez
Simmons the refugee and migrant rights
director at Amnesty International High
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us what do you think what's going to
happen later
well to be honest I I'm not sure
um all expectations so far has she
um she's been all the way through the
courts up to the Supreme Court trying to
um fight this particular matter
um the Supreme Court had found in fact
that she was prejudiced in the appeal
but that he couldn't do anything to to
assist her in in at that time allowing
her to come back to properly be able to
fight her claim to retain her British
citizenship which as you say has been
stripped from her
why should she get it back
because she's British and you should
never have been taken away in the first
place this country is responsible for
its citizens just as other countries are
responsible for theirs
she is a bethnal green schoolgirl born
and raised in this country lived here
her entire life until lured to Syria 15
years old she is as British as I am and
this is where she belongs she could have
been successful in taking the lives of
many British people and if that had
happened then she should be investigated
and perhaps prosecuted for it just as
any other British citizen just as I
would be if I had done something like
that doesn't change the fact that she's
a British person being a British person
throughout her life
this is where she belongs and this
country is responsible for her even if
she continues to be a threat to other
British people
any British person who is a threat to
other people whether British or
otherwise is ultimately the
responsibility of this nation and this
country should take responsibility for
them so yes
the then Home Secretary Sergey Javid
said if we knew what he knew
most people in the United Kingdom would
not want her back here well I don't
think that's the proper question the
right question is is this woman now a
girl when she was lured away is she
British or not and the plain answer is
yes if the if the reverse was the
situation if other other countries
National was on this territory thought
to be dangerous and this country
of whom she was a not not the UK but
some other country said that they didn't
want her as their citizen so stranded
her here what would those who are
clamoring for shimaima begum to stay in
Syria be saying they would be calling
for her to be expelled back to the
country to which they would say she
belongs this young woman belongs to this
country and so we should accept that and
yes if that means taking action in terms
of criminal prosecution Etc
then if that's appropriate that should
be done but it doesn't change that she's
British there's a third excuse me a
third party country that she could go to
Bangladesh well that's a bit of nonsense
quite frankly I mean well I'll happily
explain why here she was born in this
country never been to Bangladesh doesn't
have did not have Bangladeshi
citizenship it is said
that under the laws of Bangladesh and
I'm no expert on this she has some claim
because through her parents to
Bangladesh nationality why is she any
more bangladeshi's responsibility than
Syria this is where she was born this is
where she did have citizenship this is
where she grew up as a schoolgirl this
is where she was lured from it's not for
this country to cast her often to any
other Nation Bangladesh Syria or
anywhere else what other options does
she have if she loses again today
well if there were grounds to appeal
which would have to be on the basis of
there being some error of Law and that
would be about whether
the laws that Parliament has passed and
the powers that have been given to the
Home Secretary lawfully entitled under
our law the Home Secretary to do what
has been done
I very much hope that our courts are
able to find the Injustice in this
whether directly under our law or under
human rights law and overturn this
decision but of course that is a matter
that our courts will decide and if they
do find against her she has no further
appeal that will depend upon whether
there are error of law grounds okay but
you can't go to a higher call like the
European court of justice she could seek
to go to the European court of justice
but she would have to exhaust her
remedies in this country first and the
European Court of not the European court
of justice sorry the European Court of
Human Rights especially exactly that
yeah and that Court would obviously
first consider the rulings that had been
given by the British courts to see
whether there was some point of law
raising human rights grounds that was
questionably dealt with in our system
I personally think there would be good
grounds for thinking that given all the
circumstances of this case but again
that would be a one for the judges okay
um interesting thank you very much
indeed for explaining that to us this
morning much appreciated thank you
um that will be at um about 10 o'clock
this morning is when we will hear uh the
latest uh legal ruling as far as Shima
begum is concerned will she once again
be allowed to call herself British or
will she uh again but the government
certainly don't want her back in the
United Kingdom will she find herself
um still remaining in Syria with little
hope of ever returning back to the
United Kingdom that's as I said at 10
o'clock this morning